that was our warmup we're going to use
these skills in a question like the
abstract we're going to look at two
families of curves this money kind of
the first one is is cubic curves cubix
are kind of like the natural extension
of your 7 day you'll learn about
straight lines and y equals MX prospered
and then further wrong you learn about
quadratics we look we spent a lot of
time on quadratics even this year qubits
are the next power up to the power of
three okay so they're a natural next
place to go now when you have a look at
this sketch the graph of this it's a bit
of a it's a bit of a dog's breakfast
there's a bit of a mess it's like how do
I even start with this I could pop
points in there I could make a huge
table values but that would really suck
right there'll be a very inefficient way
to do it okay so what i want what i want
is to factorize this okay so i'm going
to give you a series of steps will write
up as I go on the side and then we'll
summarize it all together but my first
thing is on what if that derives okay
factorizing is always a key step
whenever you're trying to grab something
and here's the reason why don't write
this part down but when you get a normal
quadratic like say this most of us the
you guys have sick of this quadrant down
but most of us cut just oh yeah I know
exactly what that looks like factorizing
though helps us know where the features
are okay so when we factorize this with
the factorization that was so very
familiar with that factorization tells
us oh there are some important features
and I can literally read go off this
life right what does this line tell us
that it tells us two key features it
tells me that the x-intercepts we also
call the roots don't with right where
that graph is going to hit the x axis
they give two and they give three now if
I can do that factorization tlie for
this then I can also do whether it's our
right and there's going to be more is
going to be three rather than two but I
can still find their location okay so
here's what we're going to do how do I
factorize to see I don't have a cubic
formula there is a cubic formula i will
show you in a minute because i've got a
load on my computer it's terrible if any
of you have looked it up you look
terrific why even bother okay so
therefore we're going to take advantage
of this stuff that we do here right you
ever use the remainder theorem there's a
special case where the remainder is zero
what's it called starts of it f because
of what we report for the factor theorem
right it's what we're looking for
factors okay so we're going to do is I'm
going to plug numbers into this thing
just like the remainders here until I
get what what am I looking for i'm
looking for zero because there's all
these that it made up i can actually
divide through okay so I generally start
with the first number i start with this
one okay i'll just go to test it out and
see what happens okay so 1 cubed is 1 1
squared is 16 times 1 is 1 seat and
there's 80 beers okay what's going to
happen how this 1 plus 8 is 9 minus 3
minus 6 is minus 9 so 9 minus nine is 0
now this was not a coincidence okay I i
crafted this cubic specifically so it
would do this you might not be so lucky
we talked about this before you might
try this out and then get some
ridiculous number like minus seventy one
in which case you keep going right I'm
generally speaking if there's no hard
and fast rule on this but I would test
out the numbers in order side I'll try
one and then I'll try it too then I'll
try a negative 1 and theta 2 they could
give me rich as well okay generally
questions you're expected to do by hand
they'll never really do one further than
this because otherwise like we're just
wasting time
really okay so shut up we've got 1 i've
used the factor theorem if ever what is
zero what's the resulting think that's
an actual factor what's the X minus
something that's a factor of my
polynomial if we explain this one very
good so from this since F of 1 is 0 I
would say this is part of my working
right therefore X minus 1 whatever that
number is is a factor if I had tested F
of 2 and that was zero i would say X
minus 2 is a factor if I tested F of
minus one and it was zero i would say X
plus 1 is a factor you can see there's
always this flipping around thing well I
expected there four factors in fact if
I'd done this right there should be two
more factors we're about to find them
okay so now that I know this is a factor
i'm going to divide through okay and
that will give me a further
factorization so let's start our
synthetic young I've got one out in
front and then I'm gonna write down my
coefficients right one negative 3
negative 6 and 8 you see how all these
skills build upon one another this
question never asked us to do any
polynomial division but you kind of have
to in order to make some Grantham okay
okay let's do this one quickly i'm going
to write down the leading coefficient 1
and then i'm going to do my multiply
multiply in addition okay so multiply
add multiply is and add last one
multiply and add that's a relief what's
a 0 me it's remain zero since factor
perfect okay I take these numbers and
again I interpret their the coefficients
right x squared minus 2x minus 8
so having just divided through remember
i divided by X minus 1 and what I ended
up with was this okay so therefore i can
say therefore f of X that thing I
started with that function is equal to
the divisor times though what's it call
to get that thing you end up with start
to the q the question very good so x
squared minus 2x minus a now the great
thing about this is i turned my cubic
problem grows into a quadratic problem
look at this guy I can do this what pair
of numbers will add to negative 2 and
multiply the negative 8 negative 4 and 2
that'll do it for me right so this is
going to be X minus 1 X minus 4 there's
the negative for you talk about and X
plus 2 tada are with factorized the one
that was really really good okay Oh this
process is hard but it yielded a result
which we could then deal with inside
ball or quadratic like tools and stuff
like that so great I have done the first
step I have factorized finished